völlig überraschend hat mich der brief
von oliver welke in einem 4 sterne
superior hotel auf pulau paco erreicht
sofort soll ich alles stehen und liegen
lassen schreibt er und zum brandenburger
tor kommen an jenen ort wo alte und neue
bundesländer ineinander fließen
das kann nur eins bedeuten endlich nach
all den jahren des wartens des schuppens
des rückens habe ich sie endlich sicher
die nachfolge als chefmoderator der
erfolgreichsten comedy show deutschlands
wir müssen los
fabian die loos wohin mit der online
dreh der brief von oli hat sich nur die
erste seite gelesen kommt dagegen online
3com
[Musik]
ich glaube dass es auch für uns noch mal
so eine richtige chance zu zeigen was
wir journalistisch so drauf haben
für das internet oder das ist dann fürs
internet ok also es ist schon etwas
besonderes wir tauchen ein in den
wahlkampf
[Musik]
wir sind in brandenburg will jetzt
richtig die stimmung immer testen vor
den landtagswahlen
also glaubt es oder nicht aber ich will
die ostdeutschen richtig spüren
du bist du bescheuert die sind alle
rechts hier alles af.de wenn du hier mit
dem zdf micro ausgeht was meinst du wie
sehr du die leute hier spürst das ist
mir egal ich mache das jetzt ich sind
nett hier fabian wartet auf mich ich
komm doch mit allein habe ich doch angst
hier jetzt
[Musik]
hallo hallo dafür dass wir unsere
schlösser wieder kriegen ja aber ist das
ist es der richtige ansatz um wähler zu
gewinnen dass man sich historische
kostüme anzieht und vor der realität
flieht probieren ja und wie läuft nun
leider schon sehr viele unterschriften
liegen uns gesammelt gegen gegen den uns
ungefähr
wir sind ja dafür dass wir in unserer
schloss zu bekommen ich und meine dame
musste die dame als wieder haben ledige
frau wollte ich nur mal klatschen sie
sind jetzt politiker der linkspartei
steht dann erst mal gesagt ich sehr
gelegen dass die linken hier nicht so
ernst genommen
was schätzen sie denn wie geht die
landtagswahl aus also ich spekuliere auf
eine rot rot grüne landesregierung unter
führung der spd oder den link wir
kämpfen für ein sehr gutes ergebnis als
die linke und vielleicht sind dann doch
die linken
schauen wir mal sehr gut also schön dass
sie auch erkannt haben dass wir in
satire formaten das wird mir jetzt zu
humorig hier
es wird zeit zu gehen glaube auch
[Musik]
mit das eis in brandenburg liegt sehr
gut also ist alles gar nicht so schlecht
in brandenburg wie man immer hört
na ja einiges finden wir nicht schön was
immer wieder vorkommt dass man da geht
wohl ihnen spazieren gegangen sind und
dass es liegen gelassen wird was die
hunde hinterlassen und das gefällt uns
natürlich nicht ist das jetzt symbolisch
ist ein vergleich mit der afg oder geht
es wirklich um runde es geht um
richtigen normalo im moment sowieso mal
nicht eintritt in kaum zu glauben dass
mein bruder lustig findet der kleine
streber wenn wir doch nur den job clown
es für becker kommt nochmal schicken wir
jetzt mal schön ab machen wir als die
nummer ich habe den pastor die nicht wo
kommt das her dass sie so viele leute
hier 11 dw ich denke es gibt eine
allgemeine verunsicherung ja so für mich
hängt damit zusammen dass plötzlich
alles über eine app empfangen werden
soll oder gesteuert ich kann kein auto
leasen ich kann mir keine fahrkarte
kaufen weil ich das nicht haben will das
irgendwie alle möglichen daten von mir
geklaut werden und insofern kann ich
aber auch andere in meinem alter
vielleicht ebenso verstehen dass die
haut aufgrund dieser tatsachen
verunsichert sind finde schon
beängstigend dass man mit
weil sprüchen auch mit wende 2.0
versucht da irgendetwas zu fokussieren
oder die leute irgendwie an ihrem
historischen schicksal zu packen um dann
die gesellschaft noch mehr zu spalten
das bin ich wirklich bedenklich das
finde ich auch echt gemein gemeine
strategie die auch einfach keinen sinn
macht also meistens noch von politikern
aus dem westen kommt nämlich die
autobiografisch gar nicht mit dem handel
hatten
und wenn man sich hier mit den leuten
unterhält die wirklich auch eine ost
geschichte haben und mal die perspektive
wechselt dann weiß man auch dass das
nicht alles so ja nicht immer alles so
gut gelaufen ist und es ist wirklich für
die schwierig war neu anzufangen muss
man schon genau hinsehen und auch mal
sagen als westdeutsche vielleicht ja das
war schon echt scheiße und horst hallwas
gelaufen ist
[Musik]
hallo wir wollen mitfahren
peters wirklich jetzt auch guck mal die
brandenburger so offen echt wir fahren
deshalb ist es weit weg ist es im westen
[Musik]
also das hier mein kollege das ist hier
fabian köster das ist unglaublich
motiviert das engagierte hat sich
gestern abend hingesetzt und ein quiz
ein brandenburg chris erstellt um mal zu
gucken wie gut kennen denn die
brandenburger brandenburg
was schätzen sie denn wie hoch ist der
ausländeranteil in brandenburg gehören
42 prozent was hätten sie gedacht wie
hoch der ausländeranteil in brandenburg
ist ja auch schön prozent zu sagt aber
45 hätten sie nicht gesagt ich würde den
anteil am brandort jetzt momentan
schätzt auf 30-35 sind tatsächlich 4,7
bei uns in dem ort sind auch ausländer
entgegengekommen sind ruhig und japan
serie in harmonie familie dann viele
menschen das heißt sie haben auch direkt
kontakt zu flüchtlingen in ihrem europa
und das sind syrer und das ist eher ein
paar kinder und ich sind ganz friedlich
alte ja man muss ich ihnen dann passen
sie meine ich selbst bin ja auch mal
geflüchtet jetzt kommen wir auch von
schlesien
wir mussten ja auch mal raus und wir
wurden
ich bin damals in sachsen groß geworden
und wir wurden auch schlecht behandelt
von denen ja da ist doch immer mehr
ausländer und jetzt kann ich die jetzt
verstehen wenn wenn jetzt auch wieder
sagen die ausländer
[Musik]
ja also muss was glaubst auch kommentar
auch mit dem quiz wie gut er irgendwann
ist es war also
[Musik]
also fabian ich muss echt sagen ich bin
positiv überrascht von brandenburg ich
war echt guten gefühl morgen zurück nach
können ja aber wieso morgen tritt geht
auch drei tage wie drei tage klar
morgens nach lachsen nach sachsen herz
wird super freue mich schon nachts nach
1 wollte ich schon immer mal fragen was
schätzt du wie hoch ist der
ausländeranteil in sachsen
fabian halt die fresse
[Musik]